so richard wiseman of the University of
Hertfordshire set up a website called
laughs lab to try to find the funniest
joke in the world after about 40
thousand submissions rated by 1.5
million people he finally found the
world's funniest joke two hunters are
out in the woods when one of them
collapses he doesn't seem to be
breathing and his eyes are glazed the
other guy whips out his phone and calls
the emergency service he gasped he says
my friend is dead he's dead what can I
do the operator says hey calm down I can
help first let's just make sure he's
actually dead then there's a silence and
all of a sudden gunshots heard and then
the guy gets back on the phone said okay
what now
nothing no come on you know that's good
you know it's there's a smile oh oh
Oh almost did you not hear the joke I
heard it me I'm gonna read it one more
time because I just don't think you guys
get like really good humor cuz this is
like really good joke it's proven I'm
gonna do it one more time
you guys ready two hunters out in the
woods when one of them collapses Oh No
Paul's 911 dead what can I do the
operator said a calm down first you just
got to make sure he's actually dead and
all upset a gunshot noise the guy gets
back on the phone and says okay now what
aah
Wow maybe you just don't have a sense of
humor oh [ __ ]
you get it yeah I definitely get it
without tiny life oh that's that's
that's kind of a that's a laugh that's a
laugh
oh my gosh ha ha ha so much but I mean I
don't know I think I heard some laughter
close enough so thank you guys so much
for playing Wow I am the funniest person
you've ever met look at more laughter
minute let's lift this [ __ ] ahead of
ourselves here I mean I made you laugh
like on command this joke is still the
best joke ever fam proven fun the guy
says okay now what
love it ah stone cold